là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la franche au fond des yeux ni non
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une chose que de petits
détails le tronc fais les valises à
paris de ce qui lui arrive à la bulle
comme chaque semaine france info et
l'ina vous offre un voyage dans le temps
à travers les archives de la télévision
pour mieux comprendre l'actualité
contemporaine c'est l'inattendu et vous
êtes les bienvenus à mes côtés géraldine
corner lavaud et ludivine lopez
journaliste à la rédaction de l'ina
bonjour à toutes les deux alors voulu
divine c'est un anniversaire que vous
avez choisi de célébrer cette semaine
exactement l'anniversaire d'un objet que
les moins de 30 ans ne peuvent pas
connaître le be bop ça vous parle
nathanaël oui j'avais 20 ans un
téléphone dans la poche à me faisait
rêver à l'époque en tout cas pour les
plus jeunes un des images sans pause
voici l'ancêtre de nos smartphones le be
bop fait c'est trente ans début octobre
1991 il était expérimenté à strasbourg
puis à paris et à lille et pour la
télévision c'était une révolution
les bieber ou les téléphones de poche
ont envahi les trottoirs de strasbourg
téléphoner y compris à l'autre bout du
monde sur un bout de trottoir c'est
possible avec ses mini combinées de
poche
seule condition être à proximité dans un
rayon de 50 à 200 mètres d'une de ces
bornes radio reliés à une antenne 300
bornes vont être installés et formeront
un maillage complet de l'agglomération
permettant de téléphoner de n'importe
quel endroit
véritable révolution dans le mode de
télécommunications ce téléphone de poche
accompli un vieux rêve un rêve
accessible
il ya une volonté en fait d'en faire un
produit de grande diffusion
derrière be bop évoque bien le dynamisme
la vitalité le dialogue puisque le be
bop je veux dire pour le danser il faut
être à deux est également correspond une
cible qui ment jeune et dynamique
monsieur tout le monde devra patienter
un peu be bop ne sera commercialisé
qu'en mars 1992 en attendant quelques
centaines de privilégiés particuliers et
professionnels vont expérimenter dans le
cadre du réseau pilote un délai pour
affiner le prix qui devrait osciller
autour de 1500 francs après strasbourg
c'est paris qui sera équipé d'un tel
réseau et dc 1995 toutes les villes de
plus de 50 mille habitants de quoi
mettre au rancart de nombreuses cabines
publiques
alors dans les années
question j'ai senti la lame était très
gentil gars dans les années 90 vous
l'avez entendu le téléphone portable
c'était un rêve aujourd'hui c'est plus
que jamais une réalité l'année dernière
plus de 185 millions de smartphones
étaient vendus en europe voilà et on va
faire un grand écart on va passer la
pointe de la technologie à une pratique
presque sortis d'un autre temps
géraldine vous avez choisi de vous
parler des thérapies de conversion oui à
une proposition de loi est à l'étude en
ce moment pour interdire je cite ces
pratiques visant à modifier
l'orientation sexuelle ou l'identité de
genre d'une personne alors qu'est ce
qu'un avec une thérapie de conversion
c'est tout simplement un stage souvent
présenté comme ça pour permettre aux
personnes homosexuelles de rentrer dans
le droit chemin je mets des énormes
guillemets parce que le droit chemin
c'est de devenir hétérosexuels ça paraît
complètement hallucinant choquant d'un
autre âge vous l'avez dit mais
saviez-vous que jusqu'en
1983 l'état français considérer
l'homosexualité comme une maladie
mentale qui se soignaient bien à coups
de thérapie écoutez ce psychanalyste
c'était en 1973 je dirais que ma
sexualité est une manière d'être qui
touche de même un nombre important le
sujet puisqu'on estime il n'y à 10%
l'humanité qui a des tendances
homosexuelles
dont la moitié soit 5 % pratique
réellement nouveau sexuelle
et c'est à travers les conceptions
psychanalytique je ne suis pas
d'ailleurs
intégralement artisans que j'ai mieux
compris j'ai pu mieux les aider il faut
revenir aux sources et que c'est au
niveau de l'affluence de la mer et aussi
de l'affluence du père il faut faire
remonter les causes principales de
l'homosexualité sous quelle forme et
bien généreuse de la mer c'est la mer
dominatrice c'est la mère des petites
ouvre son fils et la mère qui détient
toute l'autorité c'est la mère qui
écrase de père est d'ailleurs plus les
homosexuels ça vient le rôle de la
meilleure de l'homosexualité à l'abandon
et lamerat voilà bah ça laisse sans voix
pantois à noter donc si la france et
1983 pour arrêter de dire que la
l'homosexualité est une maladie mentale
il a fallu attendre 1990 pour que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
cesse de considérer l'homosexualité
comme une maladie mentale oui au passage
en faut peut-être rappeler que 69 pays
dans le monde considèrent encore
l'homosexualité comme un clean et dans
onze de ces états les relations
homosexuelles sont même puni par la
peine de mort voilà donc ça c'est pour
l'actualité de la semaine que s'est il
passé à cette même période de l'année
par le passé pour le savoir regardez le
zapping de l'inattendu ça s'est passé
cette semaine
bonjour
le premier mariage homosexuel célébré
hier au danemark le maire de copenhague
a scellé l'union d'yvan et or devant un
millier de personnes
une voix si la couleur
il a fallu qu'elle meure pour qu'on
s'aperçoive qu'elle était une actrice
comme on en n'avait jamais connu au lieu
de dire regardez moi cette pudique avait
choisi de passionnément regarder les
autres
james dean 24 ans 30 septembre 1955
la dernière scène des plus effroyables
une conférence réunissait à munich les
puissances de l'axé le bloc occidental
d'une part hitler et mussolini de
l'autre la france et l'angleterre la
principale intéressée la tchécoslovaquie
était absente de ce débat elle n'avait
d'ailleurs rien à en attendre
et comme le dira plus tard un de ces
écrivains les tchèques n'ont pas été
vendus simplement donné pour rien ainsi
toute l'europe centrale bascule est sous
l'influencé nazis la corde pour homps
coupable la prison pour ces d'autres la
grâce pour moi le verdict de nuremberg
vont l'espérance sont allés peuple a
pris sa place dans l'histoire nuremberg
sera maintenant le nom d'une justice qui
n'est pas l'expression de la vengeance
mais d'une morale plus haut au dessus
des maîtres du siècle il y a une justice
bonsoir ya demain
[Musique]
connaissez vous le nombre à c'est un
choix fait par des femmes de ne plus
porter de soutien gorge eh bien figurez
vous que depuis plusieurs mois le nombre
a fait des émules ce mouvement d'abord
très populaires sur les réseaux sociaux
a littéralement décollé avec le
confinement et la généralisation du
télétravail but évident oui et les
chiffres de d'une enquête ifop réalisée
en juillet 2020 sont assez révélateurs
de cette tendance parmi les femmes
interrogées 18 % des moins de 25 ans
déclarait ne jamais porter de soutien
gorge elles étaient seulement 4% avant
le confinement donc il ya un vrai car
les raisons le confort d'abord mais
aussi des motivations féministe et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ces mêmes raisons que
dans le passé les poitrines se sont
libérés
pour maintenir la poitrine des femmes il
y a eu le corset pour la robe à danser
et voici les balconnets sans épaulettes
et les bustiers la jupon en tissu de
soie arachnéen et fine dentelle ou leurs
cendres d'euros
puis le soutien gorge le sein est à la
mode et se portera plus encore complet
au chalumeau cette nouvelle forme de
soutien gorge à volumes compensée
permettra à chacune d'avoir à remonter
les avantages qui convienne à sa
toilette le soutien gorge c'est
l'emblème ultime de la féminité mais dès
les années 70 à l'ère de la révolution
sexuelle certaines ont voulu s'en
débarrasser
d'abord pour le confort et la liberté ça
tellement agréable de pouvoir se mettre
de torse nu personne ne vous remarque
au coeur des manifestations féministes
le message était plus militant symbole
de l'oppression des femmes le
soutien-gorge finissait parfois à la
poubelle comme ici aux etats unis elle
devait déposer dans certaines certaines
boîtes à ordures tous les objets
symboles de leur esclavage soutien-gorge
bigoudis parfum et ustensiles de cuisine
mais au fil du temps dans la société
porter un soutien-gorge reste une
normalité et même une obligation et gare
à celles qui s'en affranchissent en
iront pour travailler les femmes doivent
porter le tchador en france dans
certaines entreprises c'est le soutien
gorge qui est exigé en 1982 pascal morel
avait été licencié parce qu'elle
refusait de porter un soutien gorge les
prud'hommes avaient donné raison à son
employeur
la jeune femme revendiquer le droit de
s'habiller comme elle voulait et saisi
c'est la cour d'appel situe ma façon de
m'habiller et genou je pensais que tu te
sont générés pas d'autre n'a changé ma
manière de m'habiller pour un employeur
c'est tout pascal morel sera déboutée en
appel la cour de cassation rejettera
aussi son pourvoi aujourd'hui cette
volonté de se libérer des injonctions
vestimentaire est toujours d'actualité
en plus du confort c'est l'un des
leitmotiv du mouvement nos bras
ludivine l'histoire de pascal morel à
cette femme licenciée en 1982 parce
qu'elle ne portait pas de soutien-gorge
et et surprenante c'était qu'il y à 39
ans les mentalités ont elles évolué
depuis pas tant que ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui à ne pas porter de
soutien gorge en société c'est pas si
simple et ça peut encore posé problème
d'après toujours cette enquête là que je
vous citais tout à l'heure une enquête
ifop réalisée en juillet 2020 40 % des
femmes interrogées qui ne portait pas de
soutien-gorge déclaré que leurs saints
avaient fait l'objet de remarques
gênantes ou d' insultes sexistes et 25 %
d'entre elles révélaient que leur
poitrine avait fait l'objet
d'attouchements sans leur consentement
oui effectivement c'est ca ca c est le
genre et ses jeux ces chiffres donc il
est encore du chemin à faire pour que
les mentalités changent la table
histoire dé nos bras expliqué par
ludivine merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
ça ne vous a pas échappé la course à la
présidentielle s'accélère les écolos
viennent de désigner leur candidat au
terme d'une primaire extrêmement serrée
et les républicains eux ont enfin choisi
comment il allait désigner leur candidat
et cette fois pas de primaires ce sera
lors d'un congrès le 4 décembre bonjour
nicolas domenach dans votre lit suivez
la politique française expliquez-nous
pourquoi le choix d'un candidat est
aussi long et laborieux pour ne pas dire
douloureux parmi la droite républicaine
un douloureux vous pouvez le dire parce
que il ya quelque chose qui ressemble à
un traumatisme profond traumatisme dû à
la dernière présidentielle
la victoire leur était acquise quasiment
à la suite d'une primaire justement plus
de 4 millions de votants 1 qui avait
dédié qui avait été prononcée en faveur
de françois fillon donc le pouvoir et
est à eux et puis patatras c'est à dire
tout perdre et et comme père était le
poteau les et tout avait dégringolé à
cause de françois fillon mais il fallait
trouver faux font une victime si j'ose
dire ou à un bouc émissaire ce fut la
primaire plutôt que d'accuser le
candidat ces malversations ses mensonges
on a accusé la primaire et le
traumatisme est d'autant plus puissant
que au fond ce parti est un parti
bonapartiste quel culte du chef et qui
n'ont pas de chef qui s'imposent
justement le culte du chef géraldine
avant la droite avait des candidats
naturels évidemment le général de gaulle
1 le premier le héros de la guerre le
libérateur mais après lui donc georges
pompidou assumé être dans le
prolongement du général et c'était
d'ailleurs son slogan le changement dans
la continuité on ne peut pas l'inventer
écoutez le quelques jours avant
l'élection
cette tranquillité
on ne peut la trouver
que si
le président de la république
assisté d'un gouvernement où l'on trouve
à la fois des hommes d'expérience et
beaucoup de jeunes
pourvu qu'il soit efficace
assistés d'une majorité solide et la
plus large possible
puissent immédiatement gouverner prendre
la suite sans retard sans à-coups sans
dissolution sans nouvel appel aux élus
donc on est en mai 69 juste avant
l'élection de 1969 georges pompidou sera
élu sa candidature à georges pompidou
elle était si naturel que ça n'y avait
pas du tout de guerre des chefs à
l'époque oh non pas de ce pas ce
niveau-là pas ce qu'on a connu ensuite
mais au fond c'était il avait été
premier ministre de geler général de
gaulle qu'il avait tenus en mai 68 se
dire qu'alors que général de gaulle
avait pour le moins vaciller donc au
fond il y avait quand même dire comme
sion j'invite légitimité qui allait de
soi et vous avez entendu les mots qu'il
emploie d'ailleurs l'expérience soit le
sérieux c'était lui ça s'imposait
personne n'a discuté de façon s'était
établi mène depuis son appel de rome et
puis georges pompidou meurt en avril 74
durant son septennat et là c'est le
début de la dissension affiché deux
candidats se présentent en s'affichant
dans la continuité gaulliste et
pompidolienne jacques chaban delmas
candidats du même parti que georges
pompidou lui dr et valéry giscard
d'estaing et oui et valéry giscard
d'estaing savait l'importance de la
télévision l'importance de la
communication l'importance des images et
regardez il prend soin de prononcer sa
candidature donc à la mairie de
chamalières avec le portrait du défunt
président derrière lui on écoute je suis
candidat à la présidence
il me paraît d'abord normal
que figure dans cette consultation
un homme exerçant des fonctions
qui lui ont été confiées par le
président pompidou
et auquel il a renouvelé sa confiance
jusqu'au bout
alors là c'est clair un valéry giscard
d'estaing conteste ouvertement la
candidature de jacques chaban delmas il
se pose comme l'homme que pompidou aurez
choisi c'était ça la clé c'était
apparaître comme le candidat naturel
comme être celui de la continuité mais
c'était important d'avoir cette
légitimité là qui lui était contestée
par les gaullistes à parce qu'il était
un homme qui pour le référendum avec
bien oui mais est donc non seulement il
avait le portrait du président pompidou
derrière lui mais c'était de la mairie
de chamalières c'est-à-dire dans
l'auvergne georges pompidou était
lui-même un auvergnat donc il y avait au
concept aux filiations encore plus
renverser tout en ayant quand même une
différence
on voit là malgré tout la jeunesse du
personnage on se remet dedans dans
l'esprit du moment où on veut dire la
mort la mort habitait avait habité cette
fin de règne la mort la maladie et donc
il fallait quand même qu'ils
apparaissent aussi un peu
plus dynamiques en faire un petit bond
dans le temps et après 2 2 septennats de
de la gauche quatorze mitterrandisme la
droite s'organise pour trouver le
candidat qui va reconquérir l'elysée oui
elle s'organise tôt très tôt 1 au
lendemain de la défaite de 1988 la
solution poussée entre autres par
charles pasqua ce sont des primaires
réunissant le centre droit et la droite
pour trouver le candidat et dans les
médias cette méthode intrigue et surtout
vous allez le voir que la droite le fait
que la droite s'organise sept ans avant
l'élection ça fait sourire regardez
et voilà qui nous amène à la politique
avec du côté de l'opposition l'ouverture
d'un débat depuis hier sur d'éventuelles
primaires dans la perspective de la
prochaine présidentielle
dans un peu moins de 7 ans donc on a le
temps de voir venir valéry giscard
d'estaing avait lancé l'idée il ya
quelques mois pour éviter la désunion et
bien charles pasqua la reprise hier soir
au club de la presse en faisant même une
proposition plus précise il a parlé de
tournois comme au moyen-âge en lice le
chevalier françois bachy peut-être un
obstacle supplémentaire pour les
candidats d'opposition à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
des primaires baptisé hier par charles
pasqua tournoi la méthode ambiance de
fête tous les candidats sur les rangs un
an avant l'élection et dans les mairies
d'opposition les électeurs d'opposition
votent pour celui qui sera leur seul
candidat premier inconvénient seuls les
mairies de droite paris par exemple
pourrait recueillir les suffrages
question les électeurs d'opposition des
villes socialistes ou communistes
serait-il moins respectable deuxième
inconvénient cette compétition qui
aurait lieu un an avant l'élection
présidentielle
allongerait d'autant la période de
campagne électorale
l'électeur risque d'être lassé troisième
inconvénient pour l'udf cette fois avec
ses six composantes elle devra faire
face vraisemblablement à un seul
candidat rpr on comprend donc que les
principaux présidentiables de l'udf ou
du centre soit un peu réservés raymond
barre avant de parler d'un ou de
plusieurs candidats il attend que la
recomposition du paysage politique soit
faite pierre méhaignerie lui aussi ne
vois pas pourquoi il n'y aurait qu'une
seule sensibilité proposés au choix des
français
ceux qui veulent une candidature unique
maintenant valéry giscard d'estaing mais
dit il le système des primaires
américaines n'est pas transposable en
france plus d aide à réfléchir enfin
françois léotard il aimerait lui aussi
des primaires mais d'abord au sein même
de l'udf en fait on pourrait aussi bien
tirer le candidat au sort car une seule
chose est sûre pour ceux qui veulent une
seule tête ils veulent que ce soit la
leur
est ce que vous vous souvenez nicolas
domenach de cette proposition primaire
commence été perçu à l'époque c'est très
très mal perçu quand même parce que dans
l'esprit de la vème république et des
gaullistes en particulier c'est un lien
direct entre le peuple et le candidat
qui s'impose il ya quelque chose de
l'ordre de spirituel le quasiment de
magique qui s'établit donc pas la
médiation des partis est totalement
exclu il ya tellement d'arrière pensé à
ce moment là pourquoi charles pasqua
propose ça c'est parce que eh bien chers
chirac a été battu en 88 et au fond et
il faut trouver quelqu'un d'autre et que
edouard balladur jeu chaque candidature
se profile alors il ya une personnalité
politique on a aperçu tout à l'heure sur
les images qui étaient farouchement
opposés à ces primaires et même quand
elles se sont abandonnés l'idée d'un
congrès du rpr pour choisir le candidat
de la droite ne lui plaît pas non plus
géraldine oui et c'est nicolas sarkozy
un qui était soutien d'edouard balladur
vous venez de le dire il était contre
les primaires mais aussi contre la
désignation du candidat à l'élection
présidentielle par le vote d'un congrès
écoutez le c'est drôle inde et
d'entendre ça avec le recul
d'aujourd'hui
s'ils avaient un congrès du rpr avec un
vote pour départager deux candidats cela
voudrait dire que le rpm investi un
candidat c'est parfaitement contraire à
l'esprit la vème république et au
message du général de gaulle on n'est
pas candidat du rpr à l'élection
présidentielle on n'est pas candidat de
l'udf à l'élection présidentielle on
n'est pas candidat du ceni à l'élection
présidentielle je sais bien tel ou tel
développe cette thèse
ce n'est en aucun cas lula l'a elle même
bien sûr et deuxième élément je voudrais
le dire avec une certaine solennité
j'appartiens depuis vingt ans la
formation gaulliste faire un congrès
avec un vote c'est prendre un grand
risque quant à l'unité du mouvement
on l'écouté on regarde sa cravate aussi
bien en formidable mais qui relèvent
d'une autre mode à l'époque
avec une autre époque dépassé donc il a
changé de cravates et il a changé aussi
de porte si mais c'est drôle aussi bas
il a changé de penser parce que faut le
rappeler quand même en 2007 nicolas
sarkozy sera investi à l'élection
présidentielle grâce au congrès avec le
congrès de l'ump comment vous et on
explique ce revirement oui c'était pas
une primaire c'était un sacre qui était
organisée par le parti y parce que le
parti avait encore un peu de l'influent
spoil beaucoup plus que ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui mais donc s'étaient
organisés pour que au fond il ya quelque
chose le mot sacre est important parce
qu'il y avait quand même quelque chose
de religieux qui s'est passé à ce moment
là c'était une vraie un rituel une
liturgie qui comptait pour propulser le
candidat avec des forces que avait
encore le parquet nicolas on va revenir
en
1995 à cette époque pas de primaires un
nid de congrès jacques chirac annonce sa
candidature
seul et ce dès le mois de novembre 1994
edouard balladur se présentent aussi
c'est en janvier 1995 c'est inédit deux
candidats pour un seul parti
c'est totalement inédit et ça fait un
choc en plus dans les dents dans le
parti parce qu'au fond edouard balladur
avait pris un engagement et il avait
passé un pacte entre ce qu'on appelait
les deux amis de trente ans bien leur
balladur et jacques chirac il s'était
engagé à ne pas se présenter s'il
devenait premier ministre par le pacte
été rompues donc il y avait vraiment une
scission déchirure dans le parti et la
nicolas sarkozy avait raison de dire que
le parti était déchirée alors pour
l'élection 2007 on l'a vu c'est un
congrès militants acquis à voter pour
nicolas sarkozy même temps c'était le
seul candidat car dominique de villepin
son principal concurrent s'est retiré à
cause des affaires clearstream et les
affaires c'est aussi ce qui va entacher
le candidat en 2016 oui vous le disiez
tout à l'heure en introduction pourtant
tout partait bien pour une fois enfin la
droite le centre droit avait réussi à
mettre au point une primaire élargie
françois fillon est élu candidat mais
voilà patatras lépine dans le pied le
caillou dans la chaussure
il est rattrapé par des soupçons
d'emplois fictifs sens à ces primaires
aurait été vraiment une réussite non ah
oui chez check est une réussite on
n'avait jamais vu isation partisane
comme ça alors que les parties s'étaient
affaiblies comme je vous le disais et
avec un mystère qui demeure encore
comment on fond nicolas sarkozy a pu
être aussi mauvais dans ces primaires là
alors qu'il était le meilleur parce que
ça ne fait aucun doute ils étaient
plusieurs coups des au dessus de tous
les autres concurrents alain juppé ou
soit fillon des anciens premiers
ministres mais il avait raison d'être
contre la primaire parce qu'au fond
c'était pas son mode de d'exercice
d'expression dire de par d'arriver au
fond à l'emporter contre ce qu'ils
avaient dominés à qui il avait commandé
doit pendant des années il n'a pas su
affronter ce qui est un exercice rituel
très différent de toutes les autres
compétitions auxquelles il a été
confronté est ce que le traumatisme de
2016 a disparu ah non ils perpétuent il
se perpétue puisque au fond ils n'ont
pas voulu faire l'analyse du pourquoi de
l'échec ils ont reporté la
responsabilité sur cette primaire qui
aura été maquillés tronqués par des
votants venu de la gauche 1 et qui
aurait au fond on fait battre nicolas
sarkozy est donc ce serait l'explication
mais donc ils tant qu'ils n'auront pas
résolu ça veut dire qu'ils n'auront pas
de primaires d'ailleurs ils n'y ont pas
arrivés cette fois ci à se prononcer
pour une primaire ouverte alors
justement qu'est ce qui va se passer le
4 décembre va il va se passer que sans
doute les sondages vont régler le
problème avant si je peux me permettre
c'est à dire encore pire que ce qu'ils
faisaient ce à quoi ils avaient pensé
c'est à dire qu'au fond il y aura sans
doute quelqu'un qui va cristalliser à
droite veut dire le la candidat la fin
de la capacité de battre le président de
la république sortant et nous comme vous
et on gardera un oeil sur cette journée
du 4 décembre merci à vous nicolas
domenach merci à vous géraldine pour
pour ce dossier avant de refermer cette
inattendue nicolas je ne sais pas si
vous savez nous avons une petite
tradition nous avons une pépite une
archive un solide cette semaine avec le
mariage de deux funambules c'était en
1954 à toulouse à 15 mètres de hauteur
regardez
c'est un mariage comme les autres on le
croirait que berthe sommes en causes qui
21 ans épouse roger deux fusils ce 26
ans rien que de très normal que les deux
jeunes époux sur des funambules de
grande classe voilà qui change un peu
les choses c'est pourquoi sur la place
du capitole de toulouse qui n'en vit
jamais tant les deux jeunes mariés se
sont vu donner la bénédiction à 15
mètres du sol par l'abbé simon célèbre
par ses plongeons dover mariage
authentiquement funambulesque dans les
philosophes pour en tirer cette
conclusion le bonheur dans le mariage de
tient bien souvent qu'à un fil
[Musique]
[Rires]
pas prêcher la chute
j'allais la faire le fils de l'amour
merci à vous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine sur le canal 27 c'est toute la
semaine sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit sony n'a ou de france info émission
préparée avec les documentalistes
florence tu sais aimé hong à la merci à
eux et merci à vous d'être là chaque
semaine
[Musique]